ok one long le break the
mle so we finish talking about
based
le
nock ok finish talking
about learning in a model
based n
zen
ok
to
doing
ok les kises
ok ok
so
theo frw like to use it what we  would
like many times to do is policy
improvement would like to ass given
policy estimate
value val
function
old this the process so from policy
iteration we know that this process will
converge if our estimates accurate in
this would give us a we of thinking of
what  we would like to do in a
large mdp
space evaluating a policy seems like a
very simple problem but when you stick it
this entire procedure understand that
evaluating a policy and finding the
optimal policy are really very tightly
connected like sort
of do a model free  example of a learning
algorithm and i'm using here learning is
one the most popular one the basic idea
of ​​learning is
f and
un policy this is going to be policy we
are not going to select action someone
else is going to run and select  action
of course our guarantee of convergence
guante of quality would sort of
dep how diverse of action selection this
guar so when we are in state s and we
observe that action a was performed we
didn't select it and we see that we mve
to  state s prime we are updating sort of
our q function this is the new update of
our q
function this is our old estimate so the
new estimate would give a lot of way to
the old estimate think of this is a
learning something which is going to  be
relatively
small
and we are going to mix it with a new
estimate so the new estimate is really
we from s and we m to s prime and also
the
reward is the re
we and notice here we taking the old
functions
is
tricky
here  when come to is here we are using
the old estimate this is not q this is
our estimate of we should be
q be learning the learning keeping flex
going to be to power this could like
over
this
of the parameter
later
howl so this is
basic  let see a different way so what we
are doing is we starting from the old
estimate we have a learning rate sort of
influence how we ching the old
estimate
old
estimate so what like to show we would
like to show that indeed if we run  this
this this get the optimal
function ok so the update is really
based on a difference between the old
estimate and the new
estimate and let's for okay let's assume
for a second that we have the right q
function we have q star so if we have  q
star what would be the expected value of
this let think this is q star this is q
star it's going to be zer right so the
good
news if we converged stay there s if we
converge in expectation we don't
change so the challenge  is really how do
we get there right okay so sort of
saying that if we got there we stay
there it's nice it means some kind of
stability but the real challenge
understand how does this dynamic process
really converges well and I'll try to
give you  sort of a high level idea of
how it does feel free to ask questions
like you did in the first
part what like to show going to be
convergence in the limit and going to
bey we are not selecting any
actions what is our
precondition we would  like that for
every state and action will be performed
infinitely often so you think about it
the model based right if observe state
action infinitely then
construct
uc sort do dynamic ches the policy now
we need condition about the learning
this isort the technical
condition
fair many  places you want the learning
to up to infinity because you want the
ability to any to any
el would
squi under those two
conditions the learning will converge in
probability one to q
star okay so how do we go around proving
such a
clim so let's look  at the difference
between where we are now and q star
may so what we would like to show is
that we are going to work in iterations and
like to show that rt would converge to
zer someone el is performing the
actions given
perform actions infinitely
often  then guarantee convergence of
dynamic
process so the beginning we sort of
think some huge
space v max this is sort of the maximum
difference that we can
be would to is we can shink it over
time be sure that from some time on we
never go outside  of d1 and then sort of
by induction will show that from some
time on we never get out of d2 all this
is to happen with probability one and so
on right so the basic idea is that every
time we have a shrinking domain the main
challenge sort  of we need to
guarantee never
the
classic of
gos have a dynamic process you really
can split it into two parts one part is
sort of the expectation and this is sort
of on
trajectory another part
is
contr system have a drift and drift is
constant  on the other you have aise
process so we divide the to two parts
one which
contracts this is like in the value
iteration it has the same logic it
should contract if we ignore the errors
and one which is noise the noise is
really sort of the difference  between
the expected and the sample values ​​right
so if see maybe
if i was able to do the updates not
with this value but the expectation of
this values ​​would have been it was very easy
to show that it works
right so what i'm doing now  is i'm
saying let's think in some s i'm doing
it so the first part is sort of taking
the expectation this is a deterministic
part every taking expectation and
getting to a new point and now defining
the noise as the difference between the
expectation and what
s the the second part zero
expectation because sampling things they
should be equal to
expectation of large number any
concentration
but looking dynamic process so you need
to guarantee that the bound would hold
for the entire so need the
entire when up things going  to be near
zer for
the this is
easy compute the time until the
deterministic part the expectation part
would shrink in fact we would like
notice i didn't put h one here but 1.5 i
want like an over shrinking i'm ging
like a  factor of beta over two here in
the
shrinkage now as i'm in the ph i'm
looking at a bound on the noise and i
would like it to hold during the entire
iteration right so so i have an extra
bet over two here
this handle my enti
deviations think of doing
explicit of bound another bound in order
to bound those differences but you need
to bound it not a single point but
during the entire
iteration during the
iteration the time so when do we switch
to the initial
time bound  on the time the next
iteration will
start after the previous iteration
started and like t over k to the power
of w w was the exponent of the learning
rate the learning rate was 1 to the
power of t so if we think of a learning
rate of one  over t it means that you
need double why does it make sense that
you need to double the time because you
need to overcome
order alls
need obs will wi
theming
basic see think this shing more than i
need and this
guarantees for the next iteration  this
extra shrink is going to be my
fluctuations and my fluctuations are not
going to be that big b
fluctuations bet some parameter right
think of it 0.1
0.01 it will depend on the learning on
the gam things like that but just think
of it as a  constant and this is sort of
bet is controlling how fast we
contracting get a
recur can bound b the number iteration
is easy because in each iteration you
shrink by beta the question is how much
time does it take you so it will depend
on various values  of w so for example if
you take a linear learning rate you are
going to get an exponential
time and this is sort of i was trying to
hint why does it make sense to get
something exponential because each time
you want to improve you need sort of to
wipe out all the previous things and
this means that you need at least to
double your horizon taking let's say a
w which is a half then you would get a
much
nicer
time question i know very high level but
i you got the bic
idea need
so
no for
can
do delta
and so what was the advantage of
learning right many algorithm has a very
similar
structure now let's put learning and
tell you so what is the advantage is
this better than learning a
model you need to
answer looks nicer looks cooler  any
other
reason i think the nice thing is that
you really maintaining
okay we calling it a function but notice
function is almost policy
what you really doing sort of keeping a
candidate policy around and updating
concept keeping the minim amount of
information that you need you  need to
keep a
policy
learning
isi and the differ is getting the
a than getting the
a from some other process it selects the
at plus one
here
another
isd which lear value function the
function but all
those another
one all those things dynamic very
similar  fl whatever is on this part noce
it will zero expectation once contract
and all those things are contracting if
look at
expectations in order to show really
converge what you really need to show
is
this is tricky this is next here clear
what do
function slightly unclear  what
do this this sle slide there is of
lit
are and build sort of value function
the other part is that value function
and sel
action the exploration done by the actor
the critic is only sort of doing
approximation of the
value
do
exp those things  okay the first one was
of
policy this one is on
policy i think this is active right he
is selecting the action so
str yes and no the actor is selecting
the action so he is active the critic is
policy right he not selecting
actions has no  idea how those action
selected he just observing state re sort
of should the
action
not
algor con many times nc to separate
two run here a critic and estimate your
value function and the action and then
differently you have
selecting
con all three would converge in the
limit under same assumptions
and i don't know i would expect them to
have a similar even finite convergence
rat for this i know for those not anyone
did convergence
rat so how do sort of train a policy
this is sort of i know the  last two
slides
more this is sort of how do go around
training policy so here is one way of
training policy which is sort of
boot so think of a game setting this is
sort of the most obvious
example so you can use expert and sort
of play  against him and learn against
the expert this be expensive
slow do this works perfectly well in
practice and can justify theory you can
use previously learn strategy now given
the previously learn strategy right we
can sort of learn values ​​and now build
new strategy on top of  it will improve
it essentially we are sort of running
policy iteration
here the benefit policy iteration is
that you can
run
coning
stages
switch large
space what is l l is what we are used to we
have exponential number of
states so we cannot really keep
explicitly  everything if
you should have been more explicit up to
now i talked about a table lookup right
i had per state an entry in the memory
and updated
it when i want to talk about a large st
space this would be impossible so what
we need we need  to create map states to
attributes we need
representation in here sort of i
the functions as a pair of state action
that you have many actions that you have
multiple function q sub a of s and
really you would like to learn each one
of them
individually  so each action has a
function qa of s and being with respect
to q is really maximizing over those
functions and you can do is learn each
one of
independently sort of reducing multiple
independent machine
learnings how how would you learn such a
function
so the main  approach sort of function
approximation right so you can use a
restricted model
class for those functions what do i mean
restricted mod
cl
v
vbm number
ofb number of stat otherwise
doing no no less number of states
less number of
states
less
better so ess now  learning this function
you can do any way you like neural n or
deep learning is the new topic
around you can do decisions but do in
the next few slid is linear functions
linear functions the simplest things to
think about and s it will give sort of
feeling  of how to do it and things go
wrong
if if this is my representation of a
state what does a linear function mean
so i would like to find a set of weights
such that the sum of th i xi would be
the value of this state  right so
basically i'm assuming that the value
function is linear in the
representation what am i missing i
missing of course the way
the minim squared
error so expr of squed
error notice that what i also weed
according to the probability of
stat to minim  to in the of the gradient
so i would to update is
v sort the
difference the value that state s and
the value that i predicted this isort of
myor in the
prediction go in this direction i
should sort of reach a minimal point
right those  are the partial derivative
so this is sort of i can compute this is
my estimate how do i compute this i can
either sort of i can do one of two
things i can either sort of do what is
called the monte carlo sort of i run for
a long time and then sort of say ok
given the trajectory i can estimate what
was the true value of this state and go
back and update
i can
do immediate update basically sort
of do update using the difference
between
the
what this
is this is sort  of the difference what
should be there according this should be
like my estimate of what next
slide so again i'm doing linear
functions basically i want the
derivative here is very simple because
the derivative is simply the state
itself i'd like to update  my weight in
the direction of the derivative and take
here the difference
between what i
observe what i estimated and what it
should be in monte carlo putting here
the pen i will have to delay this ford
let's see where i have
it
direction the differ the
re gamma this is my new estimate and my
old
estimate is this so taking again a
difference between my new estimate and
my old estimate and taking a step in the
direction that's what you call at
yes
י so this is sort of would be what many
people would do in reinforcement
learning
i would
next sl show al it
sounds very simple and it sounds very
robust in fact it doesn't have the
guarantees that
like here
is one
examples so this is a very simple mdp
all the rewards here zer so  basically
approximating anything should be easy
task and what we have we have
states
essentially there is a variable for each
one of the states
unt
surprising
initiation clear
ie correctly setting to you do exp
things we had sort of dependency in the
function approximation but  for some
initialization you sort of start what
you would start seeing that rather than
converging to zero on average you are
getting zero but you sort of diverging
things are becoming bigger and bigger
rather than smaller and
smaller
so what is this what does this tell us
it  really although ok
what we should be aware of and what we
can hope to pro can to convergence right
because even the simplest
setting might not converge a setting in
which all the rewards zero and it's all
feasible another example so here sort of
that took the dynamic dynamic algorithm
here is another example which is sort of
suppose you just
minimize the squared error okay so in
this mdp you have only two
states you estimate the value of the
first state by th the second one by two
th all the rewards zer optimal  solution
should be
zer so now we are trying to solve what
would be the next th that would minimize
your
error
minimizing the squed l explicit here so
surprisingly enough notice
that is small enough and g is near one
rather than having the shrink you have
diverge
so what can we learn from this
essentially what learn
isit far as we can sort of prove and
hope to prove in both of those cases
diver the reason the diver i think
is it's really in own policy really what
we we we are estimating the states  and
reusing the estimates of the states and
reusing them so as we are starting to
reuse them again and again things
starting to
us but if more like in policy setting
that we are not sort of controlling
things then it's easy to show i think
convergence and  in a monte carlo setting
in which not your estimate of state does
not influence what you do next you can
also
convergence
this should have been
earlier so i talked about restricted
value function you can talk about
restricted policy
classes restricted models of mdp but
what i  would like to sort of the end of
talk about different model which is
generative model which is a different
mdp
representation
so we have mdp which is either infinite
or exponential size and how are we going
to even describe
it us sort we would like to have
parameters and
use would think of maybe describing su
way is alternative way of thinking of
describing
mdp about oracle generative mod that a
state ac can produce
re explicitly define the mdp but
definitely you can use this in order
simulate things for example if you want
to  do policy
evaluation what do you need to do you
need given a state in an action you get
the next state you plug in the next
state here take action
ander so generative models allow to
generate trajectory of a given policy and
then very eas estimate reward
value meaningful
model to
do build
optimal
policy what do i mean optim policy
icy for
state
op val up
toon comp near optimal stochastic policy
run see the
running so the time will sort of depend
on the epon and
the one over
g the thing is the  running be
independent the number of state
essentially you can what will be able
to show is that you don't need to depend
on the number of states in order to find
an optimal
policy box blue
box so so i'm given a blue box  when i
plug into it a state and action it
giving state i think i need the re sort
ignored it
here this is
s
isc sl give me some
sl
ok i'm not going to store it this is the
easy answer okay so i want  to compute
optimal policy so given an input state i
want to output an action right not
st
algor so what i can compute can so
in discounted setting but i can s of
compute sort of what is sort of horizon
i don't need to look  beyond this is sort
of this will scale with like one over g
and and the other
parameter i need to look
dist h my current
state the easy case have low
connectivity then there cannot be too
many things of dist
h so consider the sub mdp which  includes
only the state of distance at h and find
an optimal policy in this sub mdp
ands
do
state
ac
ok so this is easy
case in the general case beat doing
action moving to uniform distribution
over the ac
much more
comp assuming that i have  a low
connectivity so action state might reach
many states uniform distribution over
all
states is main idea so idea is to use
sampling to approximate the so we in
state
s so now we fix sort of action we want
to see how good is action a sole let  say
d
so
s samp and try
v
s does make much of s begin because we
repl the with one
state
reducing the horizon so allowing myself
to higher
erate we can
more sort used one in the horizon
so what we
have so my estimate of  the function
doing
samples now estimating for each one of i
need to estimate value
functions and for each value functions
estimating the functions and returning
the best
one
functions so the running time would be
k d to the power of this horizon that i
need to look
at  so need to show that probability we
sort of choosing an optimal actions we
have two sources of errors in when we do
the estimation we can have two sour of of
weat
to do short the second is sort of we
have er in the estimation in the
estimation of the value functions as we
going one step
ahead so the idea is we can choose
the the sample of error is going to be
small and show that the estimation er
decreases basic as
we don't need to be as l so here  is the
basic idea we look at the difference
between the qar in our
estimate this is just writing it
explicitly now we can split it into two
parts this is the sample the finite
sample error and this is sort of this
comes from
induction from the rec we have an
accuracy of bn min this add epson
control this by having controlling d and
now this gamma is really what buying us
all the power so we can set b to be
g+ bn 1 so this would give a sequence of
acc need
tool this is
s
can bn using
exactly for solving it get is sort of
this be the upper
bound what we need
need there is algor it never defy
explicit butor state it sel action it
defines implicitly a near optimal
stochastic policies whose value is near
optimal and runs  in time which is
independent from the number of states i
think those parameters are less
important it has to scale
with
disc
to so i'm not going to talk about
observable
mod
yes
ok
vmax increasing v max increase effective
horizon
so  there is an optimal policy the
optimal policy selects one of those
actions you in disc i think know what
confusing in discounted setting so if if
you have gold in antarctica it's not
worth
so
hopefully hopefully you learn something
about mdps but what i really think is
that
mdp gives a very clean abstraction of
thinking about decision making and
uncertainty definitely the leading tool
think in operation research machine
learning it could be used more on the
theory side right so we looked at the
beginning we looked efficient algorithm
which are basically used the  lookup
table we then used learning algorithm
when the mdp is unknown and very briefly
talked about large nps and i never
defined
dps okay
questions
ma
mmin
m
connected he